ainsi s'achève 84 jours et un peu plus
de trois heures de solitude
michel desjoyeaux remporté le vendée
globe pour la deuxième fois record de
l'épreuve halak les records d'affluence
aussi pour saluer ce marin de 43 ans
cent mille personnes aux sables d'olonne
à terre et en mer à bord du monocoque
l'heure est aux retrouvailles les amis
et la famille quelques secondes
d'intimité à peine avec régine et son
épouse dans cette cabine ou michel
desjoyeaux a construit son exploit parti
avec 40 heures de retard
le professeur savoure enfin tout
simplement vivre
il y a huit ans desjoyeaux était arrivé
en pleine nuit cette fois à l'heure du
goûter dominical l'hommage populaire
était à la hauteur de ce brillant
champion du respect michel desjoyeaux ou
l'homme volant son palmarès en fait
désormais le skippeur le plus titré de
l'histoire de la voile
pendant que les autres sont encore sur
l'eau lui est déjà passé au champagne